a barren stretch of desert is dimly lit
by the brightening sky
there are still 30 minutes before
sunrise but above the clouds the stars
have already faded and a deep blue
shadowless light suffuses the desert
floor
in the last few months the flat
featureless ground has been transformed
a 30 meter tall steel tower bearing a
terrible payload stands alone at the
foot of the ascora mountains surrounded
by little more than criss-crossing tyre
tracks leading three kilometers from a
now empty adobe ranch house
beyond situated to the north west and
south all at a deliberate nine kilometer
radius from the tower are three part
buried shelters each with their windows
turned towards their joint focus the
scientists and soldiers now encamped
within these shelters cannot see the
tower at the circle's epicenter
but they will soon see all too well the
effects of its fateful payload
not knowing what to expect they lie on
the ground feet pointed towards the
invisibly distant tower and listen to
the countdown as it crackles over the
public address system
at precisely 5 30 a.m on the 16th of
july
1945 an earth-shaking boom marked the
beginning of a new era of civilization
and the birth of a new branch of physics
the so-called gadget bomb which had been
hoisted to the top of the firing tower
imploded beginning a devastating nuclear
chain reaction within its plutonium core
the nuclear bomb exploded with a force
equivalent to 21 000 tons of tnt within
a fraction of a second the steel tower
was vaporized and the desert floor
melted to a green glass
dim dawn turned to bright day in an
instant as the blast ballooned and then
mushroomed into the now iconic symbol of
the nuclear age
this was the trinity test the first ever
full-scale detonation of a nuclear bomb
which would come to shape the course of
history and the field of science
the 1930s had seen monumental advances
in atomic science and radiation research
and the spectacular discovery of nuclear
fission in 1938 was overshadowed by the
outbreak of war just a year later but
physicists were quick to realize the
devastating potential of their new
discovery albert einstein co-signed a
letter to then president roosevelt with
a warning it is conceivable that
extremely powerful bombs of a new type
may thus be constructed
so the us developed their own bomb
before any other nation could
the test was considered a great success
and just 21 days later the united states
dropped a similar atomic bomb
the so-called fat man on the city of
nagasaki
japan
[Music]
if it had not been for the deadly
pressures of war nuclear science may
have followed a very different and
likely slower path
the exploration of the atom one of the
tiniest particles of matter had until
then been little more than a curiosity
the domain of at first philosophers and
then gentlemen scholars small
improvements in experimental methods and
equipment brought small breakthroughs
until the fateful revelation that atoms
and their nuclei were indeed not the end
of the russian doll a discovery that led
directly to new mexico and then japan
[Music]
as the glow from that first nuclear
explosion faded it left behind a new
thirst to understand what our universe
was actually made of
and how it came to be
that journey the quest to discover what
makes up everything would see scientists
delve ever deeper down a rabbit hole of
matter and mass of fields and particles
and even further back in time in a
century-long quest to answer the
immortal question
what is
at its most fundamental level everything
and perhaps even more importantly
is any of it
really real
at all
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question how long does it take for a
black hole to die a 10 to the power of
67 years b google years or c it never
dies it just sort of lingers like a bad
smell
that's right it's 10 to the power of 67
years
ages and the fact they evaporate at all
is due to heisenberg's uncertainty
principle something you can find out
plenty more on by watching our
recommendation on magellan tv this week
secrets of quantum physics 4k with jim
alcaldi a fascinating mind-melting dive
into the achingly confusing quantum
world
they are a sort of netflix for
documentaries with more than 3 000
documentaries to choose from on a wide
range of topics including a great
selection on space cosmology and physics
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for history of the universe viewers
thanks
[Music]
it was ancient indian philosophers of
the 8th century bc who first asserted
that nothing we experience
is in fact
real
such an extreme reductionist philosophy
is simple enough to follow a cart can be
broken down to its component parts
wheels axles yoke those components can
too be broken down a wheel becomes a hub
rim and spokes each succession of
smaller parts can be broken down further
by hand and with specialist tools until
nothing remains but a collection of
minuscule specs each indistinguishable
from the next
what then are the objects of our
experience is everything if not piles of
such specks amassed and organized to
give the appearance of something greater
these looming existential puzzles were
visited again by ancient greek
philosophers some 400 years later
considering the same problem democritus
and lucipus came to the same conclusion
ultimately everything we can see and
touch can be broken down time and time
again until an impasse is reached of
tiny particles that can be divided no
further democritus gave these
hypothetical particles a name defining
them by their fundamentally indivisible
nature
atomos meaning uncutable
today we know them
as atoms
and yet it wasn't until the 19th century
that science rather than philosophy
allowed researchers to probe the nature
of these mysterious uncuttable atoms
in the early 1800s english chemist john
dalton spent his summers in the
mountains of the lake district in
northwest england before the advent of
comprehensive maps of the region he was
an authority measuring their altitude
and distances through his own hiking
experience one can imagine his mind
wandering in these hills both measuring
and musing upon the remarkable theories
he was forming within his manchester
laboratory
for dalton spent the rest of his time
analyzing the nature of various chemical
compounds
[Music]
these compounds were as distinct as the
peaks he knew so well what was it about
their basic nature that made them behave
so differently
all of these chemicals he posited were
composed of simple indivisible blocks
that related to the elements that made
them up so methane as a combination of
carbon and hydrogen contained
indivisible atoms of carbon and of
hydrogen nitrous oxide was built from
nitrogen atoms and oxygen atoms and so
on
unknowingly invoking the ancient
philosophies synthesizing the works of
his contemporaries and drawing on his
belief in the ultimate simplicity of
nature dalton introduced the scientific
concept of the atom to the world
but of course as we know now this naming
process
was premature
atoms were not indivisible not the
rightful scientific heir to the ancient
greek atomos as scientists would
discover during the second half of the
19th century
while investigating the conduction of
electric charge scholars began to hone
in on a different kind of particle which
seemed unique in its ability to carry
electricity it could move through a
vacuum after all other free atoms had
been removed and seemed to be present
regardless of the surrounding materials
by 1897 english physicist j.j thompson
had isolated the negatively charged
particle responsible for electric
current which he fittingly called the
electron
faced with this new discovery
researchers scrambled to reconcile
thompson's electrons with the two
thousand-year-old theory of fundamental
atoms
electrons could travel alone but they
also seem to be born of atomic matter so
how could the two be related
further experiments by the new
zealand-born physicist ernest rutherford
helped solve the mystery by firing
radioactive particles at a thin sheet of
gold foil rutherford showed that they
were sometimes reflected sometimes
deflected and sometimes mysteriously
passed straight through
this couldn't happen if atoms were solid
spheres that were tightly bunched
together so rutherford suggested and
later refined a new model consisting of
a condensed positively charged nucleus
surrounded by orbiting electrons much as
planets orbit the sun the mass of an
atom was concentrated in its nucleus in
positively charged particles that
rutherford identified as protons and as
it later transpired as with our solar
system atoms are mostly empty space a
hydrogen atom for example is almost 100
percent
nothing
with the distinction between protons and
electrons the concept of the
unsplittable atom had been
comprehensively split and it was split
even further in the 1930s by the
discovery of yet another particle that
resides inside an atom's nucleus
thus though impossible to know at the
time starting the steady march
towards the atomic bomb
[Music]
james chadwick had spent his early
academic years working with ernest
rutherford in manchester when world war
one broke out he was trapped behind
enemy lines and spent much of the
conflict in a prison camp where he
nevertheless managed to set up a small
lab and a science club with his fellow
prisoners
he returned to england to finish his phd
in 1921 and pursued the thorny problem
of heliums extra mass
it was well known that atoms of helium
had an atomic number of two meaning it
had two protons and two corresponding
electrons but helium's mass was actually
twice what you'd expect from the mass of
those two protons
there must be something else heavy but
uncharged lurking in the nucleus to
contribute to that mass
through a series of inspired deductions
and experiments involving radioactive
beryllium and paraffin wax chadwick
achieved what his colleagues and mentors
could not
he found conclusive evidence for this
mysterious neutral particle the neutron
earning himself the 1935 nobel prize in
the process
and so the neutron was soon seized upon
as a tool for further exploration of
atomic composition
scientists began bombarding existing
elements with neutrons in an attempt to
increase their mass and alter the
composition of their nuclei
but in 1938 austrian physicist lis
meitner realized that neutron impacts
had the potential to do something
unexpected
instead of adding to the mass of an atom
a neutron could instead trigger that
atom to split
sharing its protons and electrons
between two distinct new atoms and
releasing a huge amount of energy in the
process
mightn's colleagues otto haan and fritz
strassmann succeeded where generations
of alchemists had failed using a mere
neutron to transmute uranium atoms into
krypton and barium
inspired by the biological process of
cell splitting mightner and her
colleagues named this process fission
and it would become the physical basis
for some of the most destructive weapons
ever created
despite her pivotal role in the
discovery and her contribution to its
name mightner was keen to distance
herself from the devastating potential
of nuclear efficient chain reactions
perhaps because of this or perhaps
because of the sexism and anti-semitism
she faced throughout her career lise
meidner long went uncredited for her
work and it was otto hahn alone who
received the nobel prize for the
discovery of nuclear fission in 1944.
[Music]
and so in the centuries since science
left philosophy behind our understanding
of the fundamental particles of matter
had itself fundamentally transformed the
unimaginably tiny apparently
unsplittable adomos could in fact be
split
baryons are the particles of atomic
nuclei the protons and neutrons
electrons are another breed of particle
known as a lepton which inhabit a
different sphere and behave in their own
unique way
understanding the interaction of these
two types of matter helps to explain
almost everything we experience and
underpins all of modern chemistry and
biology
but of course
this
was not the end
there were still many mysteries in the
cosmos that could not be explained by
mere interactions of baryons and leptons
was there more out there
were protons neutrons and electrons the
true fundamental particles or would this
step turn out to be another rung on the
ladder just as it was before
the real world explosion that began the
atomic age in 1945 left scientists the
tools and the motivation to dive further
into the world of particle physics to
probe deeper than ever before and find
out
[Music]
as a writer james joyce dreamed of his
work surviving him of being immortalized
for centuries to come
but even he could have scarcely imagined
the impact his words would have beyond
the arts in a scientific discipline that
didn't even exist when he first imagined
them
his final novel finnegan's wake was
written in such a way as to be almost
impenetrable but nevertheless gained a
cult following
and in 1964 one of those followers we
can assume
was american physicist murray gel mann
gellman was among many riding the wave
of particle physics research that had
swelled throughout the mid 20th century
new technologies had revealed a
multitude of other exotic particles in
addition to everyday protons neutrons
and electrons inhabitants of this new
particle zoo included other particles
with mass like pions and k-ons
these weighty particles are known
collectively as hadrons
so gelman and colleagues worldwide now
faced the same conundrum that had faced
rutherford and thompson half a century
earlier but now instead of searching for
the fact of the distinguished
fundamental atoms of different elements
scientists needed an explanation for why
apparently fundamental hadrons were all
similar
but distinct
and murray gel man was not alone in
trying to solve the problem while he
puzzled away at the california institute
of technology russian-born american
physicist george zweig also approached
the issue at cern in switzerland neither
knew of the other's work and yet they
both ultimately reached the same
conclusion
hadrons must not be the bottom of the
rabbit hole there must be something
smaller some subhadronic particle making
them up
zweig supposed there to be four
component particles and called them
asus referring to aces from each suit in
a pack of cards
but gel man's analysis suggested the
heavy hadrons were made up of only three
subhadronic particles the physicist was
in the habit of giving nonsensical names
to hypothetical particles and when
talking about his ideas referred to
these subhadronic fragments
as quarks
rhyming with pork but he never
considered how such a word might be
spelt it was only later while perusing
joyce's finnegan's wake as a break from
the trials of particle physics that he
happened upon the line
three quarks for muster mark
the new particle would be spelt
q u a r k
and it was quarks or quarks that sparked
the public's imagination the name
stuck
of course all this literary wrangling
was moot until the existence of the
quarks could be proven unequivocally
experience had shown that if you wanted
to split an atom into its subatomic
particles then the best way was to smash
atoms together and analyze the wreckage
so it followed that to explore the
fragments that made up these smaller
subatomic particles the same
experimental approach would work only
this time it would take much
much more energy
in 1968 the stanford linear accelerator
center was just two years old but was
already leading the charge in high
energy particle physics
at 3.2 kilometers long it was the
longest straight line accelerator in the
world buried nine meters below the flat
gently rolling landscape of the southern
san francisco bay
here electrons would be accelerated to
mind-boggling speeds imbued with energy
up to 50 giga electron volts before
being smashed into unwitting protons or
neutrons
and from the chaotic products of this
head-on collision physicists were able
to finally show what murray gel man and
george zweig had hypothesized four years
earlier that these hadrons were no more
indivisible than atoms had been a proton
could be shattered into much smaller
point-like particles
quarks quarks or aces
whatever they were called
they were real
the next 30 years of high-energy
particle physics saw quarks probed from
every possible angle experiments and
theory combined to determine how many
types of quark there were how they
differed from one another and how they
interacted to create larger particles
now physicists have identified six
different types of quark known as
flavours which are named somewhat
curiously
up
down strange charm top
and bottom
each of the six possess a specific mix
of characteristics including electric
charge mass spin and a property known as
colour which is entirely unrelated to
real color instead quark color helps to
understand how hadrons behave in
relation to the strong nuclear force
that holds atoms together by combining
together in triplets or sometimes groups
of five different flavors and colors of
quark can produce a family of particles
known as baryons which include
positively charged protons and uncharged
neutrons that combine to form atomic
nuclei
but also the short-lived lambda sigma
and xy particles with properties all of
their own
and they can also pair up to create
another breed of composite particle
known as a meson
more than half a century has now passed
since high energy physics smashed open
the assumption that hadrons were
fundamental particles that couldn't be
broken down any further
scientists have since discovered six
different flavors of quark and worked
out all the possible ways they can be
assembled to make all kinds of composite
particles however briefly
but for all the energies we can generate
in particle accelerators there is no
experimental hint that there is anything
more
it seems we have finally reached the
bottom of the particle rabbit hole as
far as particles with mass are concerned
quarks are as unsplitable as they get
high-energy collisions have also proved
that the other breed of particles
leptons are similarly indivisible but
they too exist in greater variety than
first suspected and include not only the
well-known negatively charged electron
but also the more massive muon and tau
lepton as well as uncharged neutrino
versions of each
so there are 12 elementary particles
that appear to make up everything six
quarks
and six leptons
their behavior is governed by their
fundamental and unalterable properties
of mass
charge spin and so-called color
but
the particle zoo is not quite complete
the twelve quarks and leptons may be the
particles that lie at the heart of every
physical object in the cosmos but they
alone cannot explain the processes in
our dynamic universe
why
do stars ignite
what makes them shine
and why do they even have mass
in the first place
february in chicago is cold
wind howls through the city streets
blowing inland from the shores of lake
michigan and piling snow in heaps at
street corners
a few straggling scientists holding
tightly to scarves and hats wrestle with
the door of the conference center and
rush happily into the artificial warmth
the 2009 annual meeting of the american
association for the advancement of
science is already underway with
presentations in genetics climate
science and astronomy cramming the daily
program but this morning there is a
subtle draw towards a single lecture
room
scientists gravitate from across the
centre eager for an update on the
hottest race in particle physics the
search for the so-called
god particle
the higgs boson thought to be
responsible for giving many particles
mass
this is a true race for glory a face-off
of institutions across the atlantic
firmalabs glamorously named tevetron in
illinois competing with the brand new
large hadron collider or lhc constructed
by cern on the border of france and
switzerland
the lhc had been built specifically for
this search at a cost of some 3 billion
euros
but before the race had barely begun
cern suffered a huge setback
just a month after the lhc was first
switched on an explosion critically
damaged several accelerating magnets in
the accelerator
the collider would have to close for
more than a year for repairs to take
place
giving the tevatron a clear run for
victory
so now with lhc crippled and tevatron
leading the charge head scientists from
firmalab took the stage in chicago to
present their progress addressing a
packed and steaming lecture hall they
revealed that although they'd not found
the god particle yet they hoped it
wouldn't be long before they could
confirm a discovery the center had been
working hard to increase precision but
the problem was that nobody knew exactly
what properties the higgs boson had or
what energy of collision would produce
it the tevatron was best placed for
exploring a certain range between 150
and 180 giga electron volts so if the
elusive particle could be produced
within these limits then fermilab stood
an excellent chance of pipping the
damaged lhc to the post
the search for the missing pieces of the
standard model had actually begun
decades earlier
throughout the last half of the 20th
century colliders were constructed
smashed particles together and helped to
reveal untold variety of quarks and
composite particles and yet even then it
was clear that this wasn't the full
picture
these particles may have been the stuff
of matter but they spoke nothing
of action
four fundamental forces govern the
interactions between matter in the
modern universe
gravity which distorts space-time and
sees all objects attracted to one
another electromagnetism responsible for
electric and magnetic interactions as
well as the communication of radiation
across vacuous distances the strong
nuclear force which holds atomic nuclei
together and the weak nuclear force
which sometimes causes them to split
apart
the ways that these forces were
communicated between particles of matter
came to occupy their own branch of
particle physics as a new breed of
force-carrying particle was invoked
called a gauge boson
these messengers were theoretical at
first the photon for electromagnetism
gluon for the strong force w and z
bosons for the weak force and the
graviton for gravity
as particles they could be considered
physical manifestations of fields in the
same way waves on the surface of the
ocean are a reflection of the movements
beneath the surface whether they were
real particles or not is a question for
quantum mechanics but one after the
other experiments did in fact detect
most of these bosons and now they sit
alongside quarks and leptons in the
standard model of particle physics
only the graviton eludes us needing such
huge collision energies to produce it
that we will never be able to build a
particle accelerator big enough
once they could be seen and studied it
turned out that the different
force-carrying bosons had varying
properties just like the fundamental
properties of mata
they had different masses and interacted
with quarks and leptons in different
ways for example somewhat surprisingly
the w and z bosons of the weak force
seemed to have huge masses whereas
photons had no mass at all and this
question of mass was rapidly becoming a
major problem for the hallowed standard
model of physics
lepton mass is minuscule while all the
quarks have more but differing amounts a
top cork has around 75 000 times the
mass of an upcork
and yet there is nothing in the
mathematics of particle physics that
says that these particles should have
any mass
at all
despite the fact maths can predict with
remarkable accuracy the earliest moments
of the cosmos there is one glaring error
everything comes out
without mass
and mass of course is critically
important for the subsequent evolution
of the cosmos
without mass electrons would be unable
to bind protons to make hydrogen atoms
without that hydrogen there could be no
stars no galaxies no light in the
universe and no life
the earliest theories for the generation
of mass in the universe had been
proposed in 1964
around the same time that quarks and
aces were first being mooted
peter higgs an english theoretical
physicist along with two other belgian
scholars robert brought and francois
anglair arrived at a similar conclusion
they suggested that all particles came
into existence near the beginning of the
universe
initially
with no mass
soon after a force field came to
permeate the entire universe and when
some particles interacted with it they
somehow gained mass
this force field is known today as the
higgs field and the only way of proving
its existence was to try and find its
physical manifestation the higgs
boson
physicists knew the higgs would be hard
to find and nobel prize winning
physicist leon lederman referred to it
as the god damn particle for that very
reason but it wasn't long before the
epitaph found a more media friendly name
the god particle was born
of course calling something a god
particle doesn't help to dispel the
mystery around an already complicated
physical theory so in order to bring the
reality of the higgs boson into popular
consciousness the united kingdom's
science minister ran a competition in
1993 for the best analogy to explain the
concept
the winner one david miller a physicist
at university college london described
it
as follows
imagine a room full of scientists
chatting among themselves
a famous professor enters the room and
the scientists surround them
the professor interacts strongly with
their admiring fans answering questions
and signing autographs
so the professor's progress is slowed
it is as if they have acquired mass
because of the field of fans that
surrounds them
each admirer could be considered a
single higgs boson
when a less famous professor enters the
room they might only attract a smaller
crowd and find it easier to move through
as if they have
less mass
while imagining the effects of the higgs
field and higgs bosons may require some
mental gymnastics
actually finding the elusive particle
was an even greater challenge
the higgs boson can be produced from
very high energy hadron collisions but
instantly decays into electrons or
photons but physicists didn't know
exactly what energy would produce them
or what they might decay into so sifting
through the collision debris for one
thing that couldn't be explained by the
other particles of the standard model
was like looking for a needle in a
haystack
and so in the end despite fermilab's
assertions in chicago that they could
have evidence for higgs by the end of
2009 no such evidence ever materialized
and when the large hadron collider fired
back up and started its experiments at
the end of that year the tevatron's
hopes began to fade
the sprint at the start turned into a
grueling marathon that lasted until 2012
with a thousand billion proton proton
collisions in the 27 kilometer long
accelerator
but on the 4th of july
cern finally announced their success
a definitive detection from two of the
lhc's instruments both with enough
statistical confidence to discern it
from the background noise
the higgs boson and the higgs field
really did exist
nearly 50 years after they first
conceived their theory peter higgs and
francois anglair earned a nobel prize
for the final piece in the standard
model puzzle
now the higgs boson sits alongside 60
other unique fundamental elementary
particles that make up the standard
model
the current model includes not only
ordinary matter but also antimatter with
opposite charges but otherwise identical
properties which make up exotic
composite particles and annihilate with
normal matter on contact
there are 36 different flavors and
colours of quark and anti-cork various
leptons and anti-leptons plus the gauge
bosons and the singular higgs
as far as we can tell the standard model
is complete
these 61 particles
are enough to explain everything that
happens or has ever happened in the
history
of the universe
and using this structure and further
advancements in particle physics over
the last 50 years
science is finally in a position to zoom
out from the unimaginably microscopic to
the unfathomably huge
and consider how the tiniest pieces
came to build a universe
[Music]
when physicists try to calculate the
number of fundamental particles in the
observable universe using known ratios
measured distances and established
masses the number they arrive at is
almost unimaginably huge
counting only the quarks that make up
the protons and neutrons in hydrogen and
helium atoms and the electrons that are
associated with those atoms the count
reaches more than three vigintillion
that's a three followed by eighty zeros
yet even with this staggeringly large
number of particles when they are spread
across the vast volume of the observable
universe they average out at about one
quark sized particle per cubic meter
it may come as no surprise that the
majority of space is actually empty
space
or at least
it isn't matter
for all its experimental completeness
the standard model falls a long way
short of explaining the makeup of the
universe as a whole
because in reality only five percent of
the stuff in the universe is what we
would consider normal matter the stuff
that makes up stars planets and human
beings
the rest
is shrouded in mystery
dark matter thought to be responsible
for structuring the universe on the
largest scales and holding spinning
galaxies together makes up some 25
percent
it is more than five times more abundant
than the particles of the standard model
even though we still don't know exactly
what it is
and finally the remaining 70 of the
cosmos appears to be dark energy the
mysterious force that seems to be linked
to the modern universe's accelerating
expansion
if we know little about dark matter we
know even less about dark energy despite
its overwhelming predominance
these vast mysteries may still elude us
but for the matter that we can touch see
and experience we can reconstruct a
history that stretches back to the first
fraction of a second
after the big bang
one trillion trillion trillionth of a
second after the beginning of the
universe as we know it the strong weak
and electromagnetic forces were united
into a singular great force and
particles if they were present at all
would be very different to how we
understand them today there would be no
gluons photons or w and z bosons only
perhaps a single type of boson which
would become the progenitor of all other
particles to come
as the cosmic temperature drops and
exponential inflation takes place the
fundamental forces in their boson
messengers begin to emerge but they are
still not as we might expect they are
massless and with temperatures and
energy still too high for particle
interactions their distinctive behaviors
are not yet realized it takes a relative
eon for things to change
around one trillionth of a second after
the big bang when the nascent cosmos has
cooled to a mere quadrillion degrees the
higgs field finally emerges throughout
the volume of space
bosons quarks and leptons interacting
with the field acquire mass and some of
the expected particle interactions begin
to take place it is still too hot
however and the particles still have too
much energy for quarks to bind together
into anything greater and so exist as a
turbulent and well-mixed quark gluon
plasma the ultimate cosmic soup now has
all the ingredients for the universe as
we know it but it will take the next 370
thousand years for it to congeal into
something we might recognize
the young universe must climb step by
step back out of the hole that particle
physics has excavated quarks must
assemble into composite hadrons protons
and neutrons must come together to form
atomic nuclei and electrons must bind to
those nuclei to form the first uncharged
atoms atoms combined together into
molecules and finally assemble the
physical objects of the universe
everything we've seen experience today
is just an unimaginably complex russian
doll of ever smaller particles nestled
inside particles
except
it isn't
there is one final layer of reality to
peel away
for it is by no means certain that
particles
even exist
at all
at the smallest possible scales the kind
of scales at which individual quarks
leptons and bosons exist quantum
mechanics is law and cannot be ignored
at its heart this theory considers the
fundamental units of matter as existing
simultaneously as both a particle and a
wave
thanks to quantum uncertainty it is
impossible to pinpoint both the precise
position and momentum of moving
particles
meaning that they are at best described
by a probability distribution rather
than a single point
it is simply not possible to capture a
single electron or quark and hold it in
your hand or between minute quantum
tweezers
because quantum field theory says it
probably isn't there
it is little more than a transient peak
in the quantum electrodynamic field
which will all too quickly
flit away
from this perspective the very concept
of particles that fill the cosmos is a
simplified quantization of expansive
ever varying fields that are woven
through the fabric of space and time
not just the higgs field or the
electromagnetic field but also many
others all overlaid and interacting with
one another
there are thought to be 24 separate
quantum fields that permeate the
universe
12 for the various fundamental forces
including mass
nine for the quarks and three for the
leptons
like ripples from raindrops in a pond
the peaks and troughs of these
independent fields interact and
interfere with one another creating
semi-stable patterns and larger peaks
whose effects propagate further than the
tiny ripples that made them
these interference patterns come to
define the larger composite particles
the protons atoms and molecules of our
experience
and so
that is the bizarre truth that lurks at
the bottom of the rabbit hole
with the universe composed only of
interacting fields at its most
fundamental level the tangible matter
that we cling to so fervently may in
fact be little more than a vigintilian
passing ripples of quantum energy
when indian philosophers nearly 3 000
years ago imagined that nothing is real
they couldn't have known
how right they were
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
and we'll see you
next time
[Music]